welcome to this video playing group this
is semen dr. Stein we are known no vegan
Grand Master I have played him two times
already here to two wins so yeah
interesting score one hundred percent
this line now this is interesting I
didn't really have anything great there
this is currently played a bit and wide
is struggling to show anything here i
have seen games with this not it's not
so bad for black who how is it played
you form when it cannot be bad ready for
mmm is it going form probably but should
be form now okay still let's go to be 3c
to looks kind of unnatural to me okay
care about the pawn bishop c3 gives them
and give me a bishop pair please going
to develop normally it should be to King
f2 and centralized rooks wear black
fields blue black is ok here I'm not
quite sure what white currently
struggles against the slide and I don't
really have firm any better recipe than
the top guys sometimes see now then
blitz games and then then term and rapid
games
yeah it's an equal or sorry a
symmetrical I'm pawn structure and as i
said i believe it's it's roughly equal 9
a-4 may be trying something on c5 they
can even probably my am taking on b3 is
kind of man it's not a very attractive
move yeah I mean as I said it's not very
attractive but also probably not that
bad I go back to see three he has 95
stuff yeah okay
well in before a somewhat one bloke
don't resist it somewhat vulnerable what
about this huh if i take uncie eight now
actually i should probably just go back
just go back
Jim I really only thought about Bishop
c5 that's bad that I didn't think about
this move mmm if I have to take on c5
that's really really not great I can
take b5 by the way that's an interesting
move taking b5 yeah let's do that oh
wait we should be five a b5 rugae 893
check this is something King moves
yeah that's actually working hmm should
be five in I can take on c5 though
shrimp c5 check Bishop c5 whoopsie five
so i have to do this huh takes me ages
to calculate simple stuff check yeah
that was possible check check okay so
going to check here on mere probably
check
so what is he doing now some f6 then I
have rupee 7 now it should be a row i'm
just thinking about options
it's not quite clear to me how it should
play it may be like g6 King g7 King at
six or something don't really believe in
f6 rupee seven that that seems wrong mmm
interesting with
no I think it's probably just a draw I
mean what can I do a nh4 just play some
normal moves
he still distal doing this I wonder f g4
is an idea somehow entering the position
but probably this first should be good
anyway yeah geoffroy can then
perpetually attack my my pawns time
morning it's really risky stuff if I try
try to run over with the king okay run
hard check and come on really
I'm if anybody's better than Jamie's
white that's the H porn Chang will be
tricky and now he forces the drawn
check check yeah Mike a lot is void
really check game drawn oh yeah but to
think it's probably the correct result
yeah this is a somewhat strange opening
line here this is this line but
currently why does not really showing
anything there but if i'm not mistaken
black gets in this e5 and it's kind of
ok i don't know i don't know the theory
here maybe g3 instead I kind of just
play the the normal developing moves
nothing fancy no I know this stuff
engine wants to play 93 yeah maybe I was
this move irritated me but actually I
can take no I can go the King go here
aha this is good I didn't see this one
at all interesting okay well okay so
then then this is far more promising
than this which just seems very Jewish
but shouldn't be five check yeah this
check is real porn so as to desperado
the noid no it's just leads to the
second game where I think nothing much
happens h5 is good yeah nothing to do
it's just a draw if i move the porn app
check is going to check me here and i'm
not quite sure if i can yeah i mean this
can be tried I mean
but it is very very risky especially if
you have less time on the clock here
second then then black is coming as well
you know the best that I can get is some
kind of free porn at the end i guess i
will windows black woven the be porn and
at the end it's to draw yeah sometimes
it's just like that you cannot really
avoid the draw okay thanks for watching